okay let's talk about FoxNews propaganda
Sean Hannity we've been covering Hannity
on this program for a very long time and
the sort of tone and tenor of his
program has shifted over the last
several years particularly under the
Trump regime and lately Hannity has been
falling all over himself to do a couple
of different things on his Fox News
program one of Hannity's priorities has
been he's trump's buddy and a priority
has been defend
Trump at all costs we know that Hannity
and Trump sometimes will talk on the
phone right before Trump goes to bed he
wants to defend Trump at all cost that's
Priority One for Hannity priority two
for Hannity on the Hannity program on
fox news has been he wants to take
himself out of harm's way of the Moller
probe if possible because given
Hannity's connections not only to Trump
but also to Trump's now convicted
personal lawyer Michael Cohen Hannity
has a really big incentive to frame the
entire molar probe as nothing but a
political witch-hunt just like Donald
Trump has been doing and then number
three Hannity has an incentive to oppose
any policy that's bad for him personally
so an example of this would be but newly
inaugurated congresswoman Alexandria
Castillo course has floated the idea of
a 70 percent top marginal tax rate for
the top earning Americans Hannity makes
between 25 and 35 million dollars per
year he would no doubt be hit very hard
by such attacks
so what Hannity has now done and it's
stunning even for Fox News that this is
being allowed he has gone full deep
state conspiracy theorists on his show I
have a segment from his show this week
and I'm gonna play a few clips of it for
you in a moment and it's very very
disturbing particularly don't let any
little kids see this because it's really
the stuff of nightmares now if you're
uninitiated in the deep state deep state
is a version of shadow government
conspiracy theories I recently told you
in a story last week about Eric Trump
more or less the idea of deep state and
shadow government conspiracies is okay
there's the official government as we
know it you've got
president you've got the Senate and the
House of Representatives the Supreme
Court the FBI these are all publicly
known law enforcement and elected
officials that's the official government
that we know of the conspiracy goes that
they don't actually wield the power okay
they are merely puppets and the real
power is held by private corporations
people organizations that are sometimes
shadowy so if you've heard of the
Bilderberg Group conspiracy theories
trilateral commission conspiracy
theories the Jews are actually in
control conspiracy theories the
Freemasons or the vatic and those are
all different flavors of shadow
government conspiracies deep state is
just one of those okay and of course
there's always like this tiny grain of
something that could be considered true
in all of these that's how they grasped
people and pull them in so in this case
it's that yeah elites and corporations
have disproportionate power in our
society they have disproportionate
lobbying power they have
disproportionate economic power and
power over labor compared to Joe Schmo
Jane Doe middle-class guy and gal so
that's how people often will initially
get sucked in then they go down the
rabbit hole into all sorts of
belligerent ideas that brings us back to
Sean Hannity Hannity is now combining
the molar probe the FBI investigation
into Trump being a Russian asset which
we learned about over the weekend and a
whole bunch of other stuff into this
neat and tidy deep state conspiracy
let's take a look at the beginning of
his monologue from a program earlier
this week time for a bombshell Hannity
watch on the deep state tonight this
takes a lot of explaining we're gonna
make it very understandable break it
down for you
it's the abuse of power corruption
remember we've been telling you all
about this it is tonight far worse than
we have ever known up until this point
yeah it's hard to explain because it's
all lies I like how he says it says this
is this is difficult to explain yeah
because it's not real Sean and I'm not
going to subject you to the entire
fourteen minute thing it's out there if
you want it
but check out some of these key moments
we now know top people within the FBI
filled with hatred and frankly
anti-trump rage have put us all IDE all
values and their blatant political bias
we're seeking redemption for the firing
of James Comey they actually plotted to
destroy your duly elected president and
this goes way beyond what we already
knew up until this point so this is all
total hyperbole what actually happened
is the FBI was distraught over the facts
and they decided to investigate Trump
which is exactly what they should do
they should just go where the evidence
points them we'll skip ahead a little
bit here at which point we get to the
following admission of corruption and
abuse of power by people that are
unchecked a bureaucracy unto itself
unlimited powers no accountability is
any of this good for America this is
just the best unchecked power and people
a bureaucracy with unlimited power and
no accountability Trump hired most of
these people or chose for them to stay
in their positions and they're mostly
Republicans and the check on their power
is that Trump aspire to force the bunch
of them to resign this is exactly the
stuff that trumpets and the fox fiends
as I call them they are mesmerized by
this stuff they see this story and they
come away outraged without realizing
that there's absolutely no substance
here and then Hannity goes deep state in
full these deep state officials that we
have been done covering now for nearly
two years did they do anything other
these top officials than hate the
President and are you really surprised
remember these are the same bureaucrats
they openly rooted for Hillary Clinton
to win the election Peter struck texting
that Hillary Clinton should win a
hundred million to zero there's this
hilarious thing where the deep state
people are sort of getting mixed up
which is that the deep state is supposed
to be a shadow government but Hannity is
calling people like the FBI director
deep State the FBI director isn't part
of the shadow government they're part of
the real government so how is it that
the shadow government is the real
government but it's also the deep state
it's incoherent and Hannity goes on and
on and on and it's all lies he says the
Trump Russia dossier was bogus every
week more of that dossier is
corroborated he accuses everyone of
being part of the conspiracy which is
hilarious except for the fact that his
audience buys it and eventually Hannity
uses this opening monologue to
transition into the so-called border
crisis blaming the shutdown on Democrats
which is exactly what we would expect
for him to do and when I see Trump
headlines like the FBI plotted to take
down Trump what I'm hearing is Hannity
is very worried that he's personally
wrapped up in this in some way and we
might soon find out exactly how think
back to how panicked Hannity was when we
learned that Michael Cohen's apartment
and office had been raided by the FBI
last thought on this law-and-order these
people claimed to be all about law and
order is it law and order to
propagandize to turn the public against
American law enforcement I thought that
the right was against turning the public
against law enforcement what we do know
is that it doesn't seem to work out
super well to go to war with the FBI and
we'll see how it works out for Sean
Hannity I'm not expecting any
repercussions though from Fox News
judging from Hannity's ratings he's sort
of failing Fox News Rachel Maddow is now
regularly outdoing Sean Hannity in the
most important demographic on that nine
p.m. Eastern Time Eastern Time slot but
regardless it seems as though Fox
executives must be sleeping or complicit
in this nonsense because it is stunning
that this is even allowed to go on it's
an interesting time to be alive and I
know for sure I will continue not
watching any Fox News other than these
summaries I get in my email which lead
to stories like these send me your
thoughts i'm on instagram at david
pakman the show is on instagram at david
pakman show Mary Ann Cooper is joining
me next today's program was made
possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman better help is an online
service that gives you access to your
own experienced fully
therapist via phone video and text when
you see a therapist in person in their
office it can take three weeks on
average before you're able to get in for
your first appointment but with better
help you're matched with a therapist who
fits your needs within just 24 hours and
you get the same professional service
and the best part is that better help is
less expensive than seeing a therapist
in person as well plus you will have
totally unlimited access to the
therapist you can talk to them whenever
you want on your phone or computer and
because better help believes in what
they do they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service you'll get a full refund no
questions asked all of their therapists
go through an extensive vetting process
and are required to have at least three
years of experience before joining
better help so you know you're getting
someone who's fully qualified to help
you but if you don't think that your
therapist is a good fit better help lets
you switch to someone new at anytime if
you've been thinking about getting
involved with therapy you should really
check out better help just click the
link underneath this video